the sunday night game buffalo and
pittsburgh uh one of the better games of
the weekend it was close early the bills
eventually pulled away let's hear from
ben roethlisberger the quarterback of
the pittsburgh steelers immediately
after the 26-15
defeat if i don't play good enough
football then i need to hang it up but
um you know i still feel like i can you
know do do enough things to help this
team win football games and
i'm gonna do everything i can to get us
back on track
this is a team with shaken faith after
winning 11 in a row you don't want to be
losing back-to-back games in december
that's when you're supposed to be
playing your best football and rising to
the challenge warning signs galore for
the pittsburgh steelers the offense
still way out of balance between run and
pass they're not getting it done with
the run james connor had 10 carries for
18 yards in his return from a couple of
games on the covet 19 reserve list what
did you see in the film that that shed
light on why the steelers offense still
can't move the way it needs well you i
mean we we
what we thought or suspected right from
watching the game on tv sunday night is
is kind of true to what we see you know
in
you know what i saw on film it wasn't a
whole lot different you know the the
predictability within their
predictableness right or whatever the
hell i said yesterday that's true
there's just no fear of that offense
right now you know there's no room for
error if you're going to throw the ball
every time yeah you can't drop passes
and we know that
but at the same time you know with
defenses and a guy like mcdermott who's
very creative you know he he had no fear
he could play it different ways last
night mike i mean or two nights ago hey
we're gonna show the blitz and you know
then we'll drop out and there's the
short passes and we'll hit them as soon
as they catch it or maybe we'll cause an
interception like we saw or whatever
that may be or you can just blitz
everybody and go they're going to throw
it short and then we just got to come up
and make the tackle because you kind of
know where the ball is going they're
going to be in the shotgun they're going
to throw it short there's not enough
diversity there with what they do they
got to change it up a little bit you
know and that that to me is really the
biggest issue they're not going to
change into a running football team
that's not going to happen sure you'd
like to run a little just so maybe they
can have the token play action every now
and then but really
ultimately to me what they got to do is
just expand what they do
you know more more ideas in the past
game keep the tight end and running back
into block sometimes so big ben feels
comfortable with a seven-man protection
mic and then he could have three
receivers to his side you could have
juju and deante johnson and claypool on
a three-man bunch to your left the tight
end and running back to your right
seven-man protection hey guys go down
the field and we're gonna work some
great combinations to do stuff like that
that's to me
just where it has to go but yeah they're
in a stall point right now with just
short passes four yards four yards four
yards and that formula is just too
predictable and it's not going to get
them to a super bowl or where they want
to go
question yes because this isn't an issue
of the steelers not having receivers
with the ability to get down the field
and and look i i'd have to go back and
study every game carefully see how often
this happens but as we've seen the trend
it's short past short past short pass is
there a concern
that maybe ben can't fire it down the
field the way he used to post elbow
surgery is that the reason why they're
not throwing it down the field i i don't
think so i it's crossed my mind it has
but i think we've seen enough through
the year to go no the deep ball's there
you know he he can do it it's got to be
a little bit more of the mindset of the
offense and you know whether that's him
or
you know uh offensive coordinator uh
randy um what the heck's his last name
i'm victor vickner excuse me maybe maybe
he doesn't want maybe he can do it but
he doesn't want to push it but that's
what i because you right
you know i i still can do it but i'm not
going to do it 10 times a game anymore
i'm not doing that because then i'm
going to need another elbow surgery i
mean that may be in his brain it could
be i mean that and i think the other
thing that comes to me you know comes to
mind again with older quarterbacks is
just do you want to stand in there and
take the hit to throw the 25-yard
completion or the 40-yard bomb down the
sideline that is the big thing we've
seen that with brady right we've seen it
even a little with philip rivers where
it's hey i don't want to get hit let me
get the bottom my hand oh i think he's
gonna be open oh no there's three
defenders there interception you know
that so that they have to do
you know something to talk to him
so he doesn't change the play or do
something like that to go hey we gotta
find an aggressive more of an aggressive
way to throw the football game throw the
football mike they had one third down
conversion in the football game and you
know what they did they kept the tight
end in the block they kept the running
back into block and juju smith schuster
ran like a 15-yard crosser and that was
the only third down they converted
throughout the night but that to my
point is what i think they need to do
because they're not going to become a
ground and pound and start to dominate
you in the run game this late in the
season that's not going to happen
i got another theory for you because i'm
just kind of searching and trying to be
creative here to figure out what's going
on he is throwing the ball down the
field he's the fourth in the nfl in deep
pass attempts so if he's concerned about
the elbow it's not keeping him from
throwing it deep however he's 20th in
passer rating on deep passes is this
part of the politics of the quarterback
position where his numbers are going to
be better if he throws it short is that
creeping into this you you know you
believe that that's a factor for some
quarterbacks and
uh you know when when
is it a factor for him especially when
he was in that mvp discussion was he
maybe trying to protect his numbers and
pump his numbers up by throwing the ball
short instead of airing it out risking
interceptions and risking hurting his
overall statistics for a given game i i
hope not you know i i you know i
listen i do i think but you know that
happens i do know that
you're totally i know i know you're
right it does happen i'm not
i i'm i'm hoping he's past that do i
think he wants to throw the ball more at
times and doesn't you know hand the ball
off or an rpo or checks to a pass
because of stats and the political part
of the game and all that yes you know
that's true i i've that's crossed my
mind many times this year i've said that
i think that is true with him but i
don't think the deep ball thing is
necessarily true i think it's a little
bit about
hey this is how we play
you know we're going to control the
clock we got a lot of ways to throw the
ball short and be efficient that way and
it's worked until these last few games
and now hey there's there's a book out
there on what to do and how to stop them
a little bit and now this is their time
to you know have an answer for that book
and go okay this is what we got to do to
change it up but obviously something's
got to be done there and they just can't
let mike it can't always be third and
four
and we run five yard routes across the
field it's third and three and we run
four yard routes and jam it in there for
the first down it's third and six and we
run seven yards seven yards to get you
know the first down there's way too much
of that and that's what i mean by the
predictability within their
predictableness my great english
i i still am fascinated by these various
dynamics that apply to the steelers as
we get a quarterback who is a hall of
famer who is trying to add to his legacy
he spoke before the season of an
objective to win
lombardi trophies multiple
during the whatever remaining time he
has left there's an urgency there i
think at some level he'd be thinking you
know what i'm gonna this is this is my
career that's ending not these other
guys i know my career only has so much
time left
and i'm going to be responsible for what
happens and and it may just be
that
it's
when you're the highest paid guy in the
team and the most important player in
the team there really is no one there to
rein you in and that may be the problem
finding a balance where they can get him
to control himself right because he sees
the end of his career coming and he's
convinced himself that he's the key to
the steelers getting to where they want
to go and as of right now they're not
going to number one seed the chiefs hold
it and by all appearances and all
likelihoods the chiefs will end up with
that number one seed so the steelers
won't get a much needed week off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports